Stratton and colleagues call their final technique regularization,
and regularization is all about load balancing.
Load balancing is a problem that's plagued parallel programming since its inception.
Now to illustrate the idea of load imbalance,
let's go back to our example for technique 5 where we were binning the cities of the United States.
If you look at this map you'll notice that the cities aren't spread out evenly.
Some grid cells are going to have a lot of cities,
like up in this region,
and some grid cells are going to have relatively few cities.
So any threads that are adding up the city population to nearby cities in these cells--
they've got a lot of work to do, right?
They've got lots of cities to look at in the neighboring cells
so that they can look at those cities and compute distances.
So any threads that are adding up the city population and cells up here have a lot of work to do.
They've got a lot of cities to compare to,
while other threads that are in the same warp or the same block
might be responsible for a city in 1 of these grid cells
and have a lot less work to do,
and so it will complete quickly and sit around waiting for these long running threads.
This is an example--a classic example of load imbalance.
So regularization is all about reorganizing the input data to reduce load imbalance.
In other words you're taking irregular parallelism and turning it into regular parallelism.
For example, in the US cities' example we've been looking at
some bins might contain more cities than the average bin,
so you can imagine provisioning each bin to have a fixed number of cities, say 5,
and then have a special way of handling those relatively few overflow cities.
For example, you might handle the cities or grid cells that overflow on the CPU,
or you might use a different kernel that implements a different algorithm
such as sorting the cities by longitude or latitude.
There are many ways you could do this computation that we were trying to do
with figuring out which cities were within 50 or 300 kilometers of each other.
And now the storage in the main kernel code get's a lot simpler, right?
Every bin has 5 slots; each thread loops over exactly 5 cities.
And the fact that you'll occasionally waste a bit of compute while 1 thread sits idle for a slot,
because it only had 3 cities or 4 cities in its bin
is more than made up for by the fact
that you never have an entire warp or an entire thread block or an entire kernel
waiting on a single thread that has 127 cities to check or 1,000 cities to check.
You've regularized the problem.